all right
red red where are you from where'd you
grow up
um i was a foster kid so i
was originally born in arizona
and like at a day old my mom took me
back to missouri where i stayed until
about
six years of age and then i kind of
bounced around from state to state so i
don't really have a good upbringing to
say i had a childhood anywhere because i
was kind of scattered
all over the place different families
yeah
i mean um i stayed with my mom a lot she
kind of kept me as a profitable like
cause you know um she did bad things to
me
so eventually i like couldn't take it
anymore and
child protective services came in and
took me away so after that i
got you know stuck in the system
unfortunately
and what kind of kid were you as a
teenager
i don't know i i hid about
my life as much as i could so i think i
lived a lie
pretty much my whole childhood and my
team i try to stay involved in school as
much as possible but
it was hard so you know i wasn't
understood
and i even though i have a very loud and
bolsterous like character in high school
it just wasn't like that i wasn't
popular
but i wasn't a loser either so people
knew who i was
i kind of was mischievous i got in a lot
of trouble like fights and stuff like
that so
yeah did you finish high school yeah of
course i graduated valedictorian oh
really
yeah i did wow yeah
it was a great accomplishment it seems
that no one on my mom's side ever
graduated high school so i was the first
female
on her side to actually finish school
and go to college and where'd you go
after that
um i bounced around
here and there um i actually
got sexually assaulted by my oldest
son's father and that's how i got
pregnant
i was in college and i thought i was in
love and it was
totally something different he was child
predator
you know so um
i pretty much you know to be honest with
you it's a blur
my whole life i kind of try not to even
think back on it because i'm just trying
to find the positive in all of this
chaos did anything like that ever happen
to you as a kid yeah
my mom used to sell me for drugs she
used to do bad things to me and let
people do bad things to me
but um i didn't let that be the cause of
me being an ugly person because i always
had a big heart
i just am in fear of other people
but i did a good job of like masking it
and hiding it
i actually didn't realize until recently
with everything that i've been through
since i've moved to cali
that i'm actually a lot weaker than
people think that i am
i'm used to being a control freak so
that people can't see the disarray in my
life
so you moved to california how long ago
two years ago now
i moved to get away from my kids father
he used to abuse me very very badly
and i did i started over
when he went to prison after him leaving
me and my kids homeless and
everything was going good and my house
burnt down and i ended up having to get
involved in
like things that i wouldn't normally
consider
but with the money i danced and i did
like
you know online things selling my feet
pictures
and stuff like that you know innocent
you know um but everything that i did
was
more abuse on my mental because of the
things that happened to me when i was
younger i just felt like i was just
victimizing myself all over again in a
way
but i would do anything for my children
so if that means that i got to get out
there
and be in the streets and do things that
most women shouldn't have to necessarily
do
i'll do them because no one else is
going to take care of them and love them
and make sure that they've got
everything that they need but me
and since i didn't have that growing up
i vowed that to myself
when i finally was able to have a baby
because i was told for years i'd never
have one so my first son even though he
was a rape baby
he was the most beautiful thing i ever
saw he changed my whole life
he made me feel important and valued and
i finally believed that someone could
love me other than grown men
so and you have two kids i have three
children
actually i have two with my husband um
a little boy and then i have a little
girl too my son just turned six in
on the sixth of this month so the
the first child was a product of of rape
rape
yes sir and that's your son yes my
oldest son he's eight years old were you
married
no i did not marry the father um i
actually
got with my husband about two years
after my oldest son was born
okay so so the first son is a product of
that
rape yeah and then you have a son with
your
my husband your husband and a daughter
and a daughter yes
they're actually tattooed on my leg
tyree king and princess
it's the biggest tattoo that i have
because i'm just so proud to have such
three
amazingly rambunctious kids
pretty much and where are your kids
today
um they got taken by the state of
california
and ever since then i don't even
recognize who i am anymore
because they've taken the only thing
that kept me grounded and
having some type of feeling of worth i
mean who can go
almost their whole year all of their
life i'm almost 29
and never feel loved and then to feel it
and to know what it's like and then have
it taken from me for
a misunderstanding at best but due to
the fact that i had a lot of
trauma done to me as a young girl and
then the fact that my husband
literally beat the [ __ ] out of me all
the time um
they use that against me and i'm all the
way in another state
where i don't belong really but
i felt like moving to california and
trying to get
over being abused victim and
start claiming me being a survivor again
it was supposed to be a wonderful time
here like
and it turned out to be one of the worst
decisions i made in my life
so
sorry thank you
so today you're working figaro um
no pretty much it's um i don't like to
be out on the streets like that
so i do more intimate settings like
um some of my clients like
to be like beat and stuff like that so
i'm more into like
the dominatrix type of thing i'm not
really into the sensual like
having a guy touch me i'd prefer to just
beat the crap out of him
i know that sounds kind of bad and you
do that through like online yeah
like um you know dungeons and stuff like
that they have quite a bit of them
actually more than you would think um
and i didn't even know about any of that
until i met a girl
in one of my classes through counseling
she said if you want to get your anger
out in a way and be able to dress pretty
and you know get paid
good money like you should come work
where i work at and at first i thought
she was joking
you know i've seen things in the tv and
magazines and all that
about you know dom and submissive
does it make me feel better sometimes do
i like doing it
no it's very demeaning and i feel like
my
i'm worth more than just that
and i felt like i was finally gonna get
to live that
until my life got ripped apart so now
i'm back
doing what is familiar
i guess you can say i'm not proud of it
and i
prefer never to have anybody know but
if i could just change one person's life
i mean
i guess exposing my soul to the world in
a way
you know it's embarrassing but people
can't understand
the depths of it unless they've had to
live it there's a lot of judgmental
people in this world that
consider women like me or you know the
actual street workers
you know with pimps and so on and so
forth to be dirty and
you know not very worth much but i feel
like we're worth more than most people
period because
we sacrifice things that the common
person would think
is disgusting and this is a bad world
it's a doggy dog's world and either you
eat or you're gonna get eaten
there's no in between at this point in
time especially because of the way
society is so one thing i do know is
that i'm i'm determined and i know that
this is not my life
and i'm not going to fall and let it
beat me i just been trying to get a
lawyer to save my kids
that's it so your number one goal is to
get your kids yeah
like i only started picking up clients
which i only have like three
you know what i mean because i really
don't like doing this you know i had a
good job i had two good jobs but because
i cried
every day at work whenever i heard a
little kid in the hallway or
anything that would just trigger me to
start having a panic attack
so i got fired my jobs couldn't
understand and i understand that too
because from a business aspect that's
not
their fault or their problem
but i've had a lot of bad things happen
to me since i've been in la
i've gotten sexually assaulted a few
times my car stolen a few times
and instead of dcfs seeing that it's a
cry for help because i have no idea what
the [ __ ] i'm doing
out here on these streets like that um
they're condemning me and saying i'm a
bad mom and i make bad decisions
but i didn't ask to be here
period other than coming to cali yeah
but i'm in the situation
so you feel like your back's against the
wall
no i feel like um the wall is on top of
my back
it's that it's that bad now because um
i'm an extreme person i i love hard
and i genuinely feel like
if i don't get my children back things
aren't gonna be pretty for anybody
especially not myself because i'm not
gonna feel like there's a need for me
people tell me you gotta wait the years
until they grow up
how look at i'm a mess right now what
how am i going to be
in 12 years 15 16 17 years
i'm just lucky i'm not strung out on
drugs and i'm not
that far under you know um
i could be sometimes i really think
about
are you using it all no um
i've used before before i had kids
and um i got clean you know
um i've considered relapsing quite a few
times only due to the fact that that's
what i'm actually being
my kids got taken for another girl had
some paraphernalia on her person
and because it was my car and my
daughter and
i kind of out i smarted the police you
know sarcastically like
you're not pulling me over i'm already
parked i haven't even driven anywhere
you don't even know who drove the car
and because of that reason he
screwed me and my children and he gave
me a horrible charge of child
endangerment with the intent to cause
great bodily damage or death on my
daughter
and they put a restraining order on me
and
they're really beating me down let's
just put it that way and they've
sabotaged me the whole way
so i've had to do whatever i had to do
to make it because i've slept out in the
streets
and i've had to eat out of garbage cans
um
i don't judge people i never have been a
judge of people
and i definitely don't know because of
how low i've had to go
straight up i don't steal from people
though out on the streets
i don't do any of those type of things i
don't get over on people and lie
i'm pretty brutally honest sometimes
i'm so honest that i hurt the people
that i kind of care about and they don't
want to deal with me anymore but
if i have to admit to my life being as
shitty as it is everyone else around me
has to live in reality too there is no
such thing as la la land
you know except for the ones running
around out here half naked
flipping out because of drugs you know
and i keep
telling myself like that could be you so
be happy with where you are right now
but
i haven't had any happiness in over a
year is this the lowest part of your
life right now
probably i thought being with my husband
was
and sleeping in cars until i was able to
obtain a home for me and my kids until
it burned down you know so
but definitely um losing my children
and fighting as hard as i've been
fighting and all of these
things stacking up against me you know
what i mean
um dcfs is winning in a way
but one thing they don't understand is
i'm not a quitter
so they're gonna have to prime my dead
hands
away from my kids just because they're
all that matter to me
without them there is no red
there's no me period so
as bad as i try to do the right thing
i tend to find myself doing the wrong
thing sometimes but that's because
that's what's accepted in the world
the ugly you know so because of that
i've had to go against my own morals and
judgment
just to be able to make sure that i can
have somewhere to sleep or
when i show up to a visit i have what i
need for my kids one thing i don't do is
show up empty-handed ever
like that's out i don't care how often
do you see your kids
um it started off quite frequently
and then as i was progressing
the dcfs workers started to do like
really
not so uh on the books type of things
you know lying on me
um mixing up paperwork she framed me for
a dirty drug test for alcohol and i
don't even drink
and so now they want me in a drug
program that i shouldn't even have to
take it's like i might as well be on
drugs you know what i mean but i'm not
and i've tested so many tests for them
and i i suffer from
an illness like i'm not healthy i have
lupus and epilepsy
so through all of this my health is
still
you know in a bad state but i don't care
what it is again
i'm gonna do it for my children you know
but
without some type of advocate or without
someone more important than me
i guess you could say to advocate for me
my kids are going to be another set of
children lost into the system
and i was lost in the system and i was
abused so your kids are aware
right now they're here in l.a my oldest
child
did not want to live with my husband's
family
mind you he has none but me because of
the situation how he was conceived
and my youngest children are with their
great-grandmother
and um west la so they're all very close
but if i even attempt to go
to them without permission or without
supervision i will get in a lot of
trouble
but you know and i'm just baffled by
how corrupt this whole system is and how
one lie turned my whole life
from what i thought was really upside
down to completely
on its face you know i
i go over my facebook and it like shows
you memories
and literally there's posts that i just
shared
for the past few days of how miserable i
was back then
and i literally have nothing positive to
say
it's 50 million times worse now because
now i'm screwing up my kids life
one thing that i vowed i wouldn't do so
do i hope for the best of course
but do i feel like it's going nowhere
yes
and do i feel like i'm gonna lose my
life
most definitely but it's all
in the hands of whatever i guess at this
point
sorry okay all right thank you thank you
so much for sharing your story
i hope you figure out a way to get back
together with your kids
thank you
thank you
yeah no worries
you